- Hey guys, first of all,
thank you for clicking.
You're about to watch a new video
or another video on YouTube.
And before you do,
212-931-5731.
What I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers.
It's instant, it's access, it's exclusive.
And now enjoy this YouTube video.
(electronic music)
♪ Gary V ♪
Here's the biggest mistake people make
when they go on a new platform.
Now they sit and look at their whole team
or they look inside their own head.
And they're like yo, what am I gonna make?
What you need to now do
is just consume five hours of it.
Everyone wants to jump in and be like
yo, what am I gonna make?
Motherfucker, actually pay
attention to what's happening.
- [Chris] See what's going on.
- Then you'll learn.
You'll be like oh, okay, people fuck
with this kind of thing.
You got it?
So now, you got it, for real?
- [Chris] Yeah, I got it.
- Let me show you what I want you to do.
Like, flat outlets downloaded, or not yet?
- [Chris] Nah, it's downloaded on here.
- Okay, there you go.
So you have to make an account.
Oh no, guess not.
So now.
(music playing on phone)
♪ Y'all need look at me, I'm killin' it. ♪
Now, what you do, basically, like
when you're in the cab, when
you guys are doing shit,
when you're on a plane, when
you're fucking whatever,
like right now, all your life has to be
is just, like, consuming.
You need to consume.
I want you to consume
five, 10 hours, hours.
♪ Be gone dust, go away. ♪
Because after, after five or 10 hours,
you're gonna be like, okay, I
see what's, I see what that.
Because most people come in, they're like,
all right, I gotta, you know,
but they don't consume.
You gotta listen before you fucking talk.
(techno music)
(men yelling)
You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(rock music)
♪ I came from the mines ♪
One of the reasons I really
want kids to work retail
or sell something within
the first 10 to 15 years
of their life, is I think that most people
have a terrible relationship with no.
They're scared of no.
They're super scared of no.
And I think one of the
things that's great about
working at a restaurant or
working at a retail store
or trying to sell something within those
first 10, 15 years, is you
get real comfortable with no.
- Yeah, what was your first retail job?
What was your first job?
- I've only worked for
my dad's liquor store
as a kid and then I've run my own stuff.
So I've never really worked.
Everything, up until 14 everything
was baseball card shows.
Where I really, I mean I still believe 95%
of the shit I do is
based on what I learned
in the trenches of sports card shows.
- [Host] Yeah.
- 100 percent.
(blues music)
I would probably not do this,
I don't even wanna give 'em that much.
I wanna just give 'em
a coral question mark.
You know maybe, maybe O-O five
and a coral question mark,
if you wanna go further.
And I just wanna keep posting and be like,
I'm accomplished done, that's it.
This is fucking fresh.
I want people selling these on Ebay.
Like we gotta really try
to make this something.
If nothing else, like,
yeah this is fucking fresh as fuck, man.
(static)
(hip-hop music)
♪ Hold up, hey. ♪
♪ Walk on the stage with my burden. ♪
♪ Reach for my chain, you a goner. ♪
♪ Brow chops with the bag. ♪
- [Gary] Did you set up your Tik-Tok, yet?
- No, not yet.
- You have to.
(iPhone ringtone ringing)
Hey, guys, sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
212-931-5731.
Hit me up with a text.
It's so, you know know what it is or no?
- Nah, explain.
- So TikTok is, do you
remember Musical.ly,
did that ever hit your radar?
- Musical.ly--
- If it didn't that's cool.
- It's like Triller.
- Yeah they sound familiar, yeah.
Yeah okay, okay.
- But it's way fucking bigger.
It being like Triller is like
my comparing New York
City to South Carolina,
like the size is different.
Like yes they're places,
but like TikTok, what's that--
(man mumbling in background)
Bro, people are like, like Old Town Road
is the fastest song
all time to get to what
diamond, what do they call it?
Diamond, right?
That's 100% because of TikTok.
I mean other things too,
he hacked it but like
it's crazy to me that, straight up,
on some real shit, if you said Gary,
I'm a rapper, I'm trying to win.
And I get only one app on my phone,
and that includes Spotify and SoundCloud,
and obviously Instagram,
and YouTube, and Twitter,
I swear, I would tell
you to only be on TikTok.
- [Chris] I gotta get on TikTok then.
(all laughing)
- Here's why: because music is
the underpinning of TikTok.
So like let me show it to you.
Here, when you open, when you open TikTok.
(rap music)
Everything that, all the content,
is all on the back of music.
(rap music)
- It kind of look like Triller too.
- Yeah that's exactly what it's like,
but this is 100, this
is the App Store, right?
This shows you the biggest apps
in the world at this moment.
So you go to apps, and you go to,
let's see where it is.
Top free apps, right?
And like, there it is, TikTok's
ahead of YouTube, it's ahead of Instagram,
it's ahead of Snap, Facebook, Spotify,
it's ahead of all of 'em.
- I gotta get that.
- 100%, here's why.
Your biggest want and need, is to
create a trend, where people like,
the number one thing I would do,
the number one thing I would do
if I was in any music genre,
but definitely in hip hop,
is write a song with a hook,
that has a direct dance attached to it,
and then hope or force 100
TikTok influencers to do it,
and then it's over.
- [Chris] Exactly.
- That's the culture, and then your song
is just playing over and over.
Like over, and over, like I'm watching
songs go up the charts every time
there's virality on
TikTok around that song.
That's how you can go from
zero to a hero in a minute.
You can be nobody, nobody,
like first song ever,
and it goes viral on
TikTok and you're bigger
than 98% of the artists in the world.
It's crazy because again, I'm
gonna show it to you again
cause like out of all the things,
you gotta understand platforms are,
you could go on XXL,
Breakfast Club, Be Here,
Ebro, Zane, like do all that,
be on the fucking Freshman list,
and get one half viral song on TikTok,
and it's way bigger for that to happen.
- Damn, that's dope, yeah let me get--
- And what's really cool about,
what's really cool
about understanding shit
is right now people got lucky
that their song was chosen for the dance
or the virality, but you could
force it if you're smart.
♪ Standing in the hall of fame ♪
- [Chris] Is it right or left?
(rap music playing)
♪ Once upon a time, not long ago ♪
♪ I was a hoe, and now I'm making it ♪
♪ I want take you back ♪
- This is all people do is
just make content around songs.
That's why it's so big for music.
It's big, just like Instagram's big,
but this is about music.
- Yeah I gotta--
- You see, you see what's going on?
And with the hook, with the big game,
the big game is like, this
song went crazy on TikTok.
This is right now, crazy.
All people are doing is taking this song,
and pouring liquid into
glasses and overflowin'.
If you go on TikTok for an hour,
you'll see 150 versions of this.
(laughing)
I guarantee this song, what's that?
(man talking in background)
And it's getting older by the second.
It started like 12, 13, 14 year old girls,
which is great to win
with anyway in music.
This song, how many of this do you see?
- [Man] Millions.
- Millions.
♪ Nope, yup ♪
- Now that you say that Carl,
I think my daughter be on there.
Cause I, yeah I think she do got on there.
She do get on there yeah.
- It's honestly, if I
was an artist right now,
'specially emerging, I would spend
50% of my energy on TikTok.
I would be writing songs just
for them to go viral on TikTok.
I would make a song called TikTok,
like I would just be pot committed.
You got, you gotta be careful
to not my corny, but like.
Making a dance, like basically
writing a song that says, you know,
do the banana, and decide what the fuck
a banana dance is, is
definitely something I would do.
Like somebodies about to create
the next Macarena, and
make fucking a billion.
- Yeah I gotta get on
TikTok, I'm on it now.
- Yeah, and like it's hard
to grow Instagram now.
Not six years ago, it's
hard to win on YouTube,
it's hard to get lucky and be on
a playlist on Spotify, that shits hard.
Right now, TikTok's easy.
Like some of my fans posted one video
and it got a million views,
they have more followers
on TikTok in a week,
then they, and they've been working
fucking Instagram for three years hard.
You Caleb?
Talk, talk!
- [Caleb] Yeah I have like 550,000 views,
and it was just--
- You eating cereal?
- [Caleb] On the subway, yeah.
- [Chris] So as far as
getting your music up?
- I've been trying to tell people.
- [Chris] So as far as like your music,
what you can just take it from like,
what's on your phone or it
gotta be on the app already?
- Uh, I'm not sure.
Yeah actually, you know what,
we'll take this quick photo,
and then go hang with
Caleb, he'll show you.
You should make your first
one right now, fuck it!
- Thank you.
So what's up vlog, daily V, what's good,
oh I'm sorry Caleb almost run into you.
Going into a client dinner
here at Catch Steak.
My homies Eugene, really good day,
got a bunch done, going into
this client meeting here,
that I'm excited about.
Basically just living, living, like
living the day to day, and,
oh yeah, Catch needs a videographer
so if you want to be a Caleb or a D Rock,
you should hit those guys up.
I'm sure somebody will
edit something in here.
And uh, going to do an empathy
dinner with some clients.
And what happened today, took a
red eye last night from Portland.
Chris Baugh, and, I don't fucking,
I don't fucking know you guys.
I'm not a circus monkey,
bottom line is this.
We fucking did shit, I'm doing more shit,
it's 8:30 on a Thursday off a red eye
and I haven't even fucking started,
that's how I live my fucking life.
See ya.
(man mumbling behind camera)
That's fine.
- [woman] Hello, I'm a huge fan.
(chatting together)
Thank you so much.
- [Photographer] One, two three.
- Thanks so much, it's a pleasure!
(restaurant chatter)
- [Man] I'm like where did he go!
(music drowning out conversations)